Hi, I'm Theodore Kim.
I'm associate professor
of computer science
here at Yale University,
and I co-lead the Yale
Computer Graphics Lab,
which we are in right now.
I investigate physics
based animation problems
for film and for video games
and for VR environments.
One thing we've been interested
in lately is human hair.
You can see it's
just a bunch of strands.
If you really look deeply
at the math for computing
human hair,
it's actually really formulated
for very straight hair.
So this is here.
You've probably seen shampoo
commercials
where at the very end somebody
does a toss of their head
and there's a great wave of
hair that flicks back.
So most hair
algorithms have been developed
for this kind of hair, but
there's lots of kinds of hair.
There's very curly hair
and afro-textured hair.
This actually
has not been examined
almost at all in computer
graphics.
So right now we are developing
algorithms for realistically
simulating the motion of
extremely tightly curled hair.
One of the first things
that we do is
we try to look at
lots of references
and then we dig into the math
[solving problem]
and we say, “What equations can
we come up with that
will efficiently capture these
important visual features?”
Many of you probably have seen
the Pixar movie Soul,
[trombone plays]
which actually has lots of
afro-textured and kinky hair
in it, simulating this hair
even for the people at Pixar,
it was actually still
quite difficult
because these tools,
they were not really made
for this type of hair.
Hundreds of researchers
over decades around the world
have poured lots
and lots of effort
into understanding precisely
what sort of math goes into this
sort of realistic depiction,
and this equivalent effort
has just not been invested
into afro-textured
and kinky hair yet.
So our hope is that
if we develop new math, new
physics, and new algorithms,
then maybe next time around
it'll be much easier to make.
[discussing problem]
What I really look
forward to is in the future
when I watch movies,
I don't feel, “Oh, I see
they had to make a story
decision based on the technology
of straight hair.”
They could make any story choice
that they wanted to,
and there is just
a huge diversity of hair.